معنا عبر الهاتف من القاهره السفير دياب
اللوح سفير فلسطين لدى مصر ساعه السفير
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
الى اين وصلت الوساطه المصريه
بطبيعه الحال
في ظل احداث من هذا النوع
مصر تتدخل بشكل عاجل وبشكل فوري من اجل
تهدئه الوضع ووقف العدوان الذي يتعرض له
الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه او في القدس
او في انحاء الاراضي الفلسطينيه ما حصل
الفجر اليوم في قطاع غزه هو جريمه
اسرائيليه تضاف الى سلسله الجرائم التي
ترتكبها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني وهذه الجريمه تعكس
المنهجيه العدوانيه الاسرائيليه ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
وهي جريمه غير مبرره وبمره اسرائيليه او
بدون اي سبب طالت المواطنين الفلسطينيين
مما تسبب في استشهاد ثلاثه عشر مواطنا
فلسطينيا
وبعد الظهر اليوم ايضا تم اغتيال
المواطنين الفلسطينيين الاخرين
كما تفضلتم خمسه عشر شهيدا في قطاع غزه
وبالتزامن ايضا كانت عمليه في نابلس ايضا
هناك اقتحام كان صباح هذا اليوم الى مدينه
نابلس وتم اعتقال المواطنين واصابه حوالي
عشره من المواطنين الفلسطينيين وفي الخليل
ايضا هذه حمله اسرائيليه مسعوره ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني نعم كيف تنظرون الى التصريحات
الاسرائيليه التي اعقبت هذه العمليه
الدمويه
هناك حديث على ان اسرائيل سترد بشكل قوي
في حال ما اذا استهدفت من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه وهي مستعده لاي سيناريو
بما فيها الحرب المطوله
هذه التصريحات الاسرائيليه تعكس العنجهيه
الاسرائيليه والصلف الاسرائيلي بالتمادي
في مثل هذه الجرائم وكما تعلمون ان
اسرائيل حينما تلجا الى مثل هذه العمليات
وارتكاب مثل هذه الجرائم انما تريد هي
تصدير الازمه الداخليه وتوحيد الصفوف
الداخليه في ظل ما تعنيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من انقسامات ومن
معارضه لها ولبيد زعيم المعارض
الاسرائيليه يقول انه يريد ان يغلق الحساب
لا اعرف اي حساب يقصد يريد ان يغلقه مع
الشعب الفلسطيني الحساب بالنسبه لنا حينما
يغلق هو انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لارض
دوله فلسطين بشكل كامل
انه اغلقت الحساب مع حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
هل المواجهه هذه بين اسرائيل والجهاد
الاسلامي فقط في في غزه
ام هي حتى مع حماس ايضا
نحن نعتبر ان اسرائيل تستهدف الشعب
الفلسطيني تستهدف المواطنين الفلسطينيين
والنيران الاسرائيليه والرصاص الاسرائيلي
والعمليات اعدام خارج القانون تستهدف جميع
الشعب الفلسطيني
والاحتلال الاسرائيليه يميز بين مواطن
فلسطيني مواطن اخر على اساس اي انتماء
حينما يستهدف مواطنين من حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي او من اي حركه سياسيه اخرى فانما
هو يستهدف مواطن فلسطيني وهذا عمل البدان
وعمل مرفوض وجريمه مكتمه الاركان نحن سوف
اسالكم عن نقطه اخرى بدات لافته في هذه
العمليه المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
زعم ان طارق عز الدين احد القاده الذين تم
اغتيالهم اليوم كان يحاول انشاء عمليه
لتصنيع الصواريخ في الضفه الغربيه هل هناك
تصنيع للصواريخ في الضفه ساعه السفير
انا كدبلوماسي موجود في القاهره ليس لدي
معلومات وليس لدي علم بهذا الامر وهذا
ادعاء اسرائيلي يعني غير مثبت وغير مؤكد
وكيف يعني لشخص موجود في غزه يريد ان يصنع
صواريخ في جنين كيف سيرسلها الى جنين يعني
هذه يدعاءات اسرائيليه غير مبرره وغير
صحيحه لتبرير هذه الجريمه التي ارتكبت في
غزه بدم بارد ضد مواطنين فلسطينيين وهم
نيام في بيوتهم لذلك هم
يسوقون ذرائع وهميه لا اساس لها من الصحه
لتبرير هذه الجريمه اشكركم شكرا جزيلا على
هذه المداخله معنا من القاهره السفير
الديه باللوح سفير فلسطين لدى مصر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات